A good example of collaboration is to
look at the international space station.
The International Space Station is
arguably one of the most complex
complicated structures ever built.
It's bigger than a football field if it
was on the earth and we'll weigh about a
million pounds a.
It is an amazing orbiting research
facility and it was built in space by 15
nations.
Some of these nations were not always
the best of friends.
In some cases they were on opposite
sides of the Cold War and opposite
opposite sides of the space race and
what enabled this to happen in space.
What enabled this construction project,
what enabled enabled this amazing
accomplishment of humanity was the
willingness to set aside our differences
and work together towards a common goal.
And what we did is we found something
that we agreed on in this particular
case,
space exploration,
and we decided to work through that and
what developed is personal
relationships.
People got to know each other.
They got to see that their hopes and
dreams and their motivation for being in
the space program and being in the space
business were the same.
And through those personal
relationships,
trust developed and through that trust,
that trust that was built through those
personal relationships enabled the
program to weather the storms,
the weather,
the,
the eventual bumps in the road and the
crises that occurred.
And I think that is a,
that is a really good lesson that we can
apply.
We can take the lesson that built the
international space station and bring it
down to earth.
We could put it in the context of a
rapidly developing hyper interconnected
global society and realize that we can
do amazing things here on earth by
applying that same level of
collaboration.
I think the secret sauce,
if you will,
was to seek the low hanging fruit,
seek those things that we do agree on,
and use that to build relationships and
to build the platform through which we
can then start to address the things
that we don't agree on.